du collectif un autre monde ancien
président de la ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin de 80 et 83 va me
rejoindre c'est de la colline d'élencour
dont il va Têtre question et la
possibilité d'y installer une piste de
ski lui s'y oppose voici ce qu'en
pensent quelques-uns des aons courtois
que Patrick Jacques de dixmud a
rencontré je suis plutôt partente oui
pourquoi pas après tout
essayons ce serait intéressant
j'étais pas au courant mais ça sera très
intéressant parce que c'est il nous
manque aussi un peu de loisir dans le
coin ben ça peut être intéressant pour
les gens qui partent pas au sport divers
avoir les pistes à proximité pourquoi
pas après faut une question de coût et
de prix la participation de chacun de la
collectivité enfin le Conseil Général et
voilà quoi il y a il y a plein de gens
qui sont parties prenantes ouais non je
pense que ça peut être ça peut être
intéressant surtout pour les jeunes ça
peut être un projet qui peut leur plaire
qui pe qui voilà qui pe leur apporter
une animation assez différente je parle
pour englober la la l'île-de France La
banle Parisienne piste de ski oui
éventuellement pourquoi pas c'est il y a
du potentiel
mais après faut voir les les le tarif
euh je pense que ça serait pas vraiment
une bonne idée hein franchement je pense
que ça serait super mal placé et puis ça
coûterait de l'argent pour rien non ben
je la trouve très jolie comme ça moi si
elle pouvait rester comme ça ça serait
bien aussi l'escalader c'est sympa alors
avec de la du ski je non non d'une c'est
pas écolo parce qu'il va falloir mettre
les canons à neige quand même parce que
c'est pas la neige qu'on a durant
l'année qu'on va avoir des des super
pistes et non je la trouve bien comme ça
moi
alors le vote bonsoir merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation je le disais
vous êtes vous opposé à ce projet de
station de ski sur la colline des
lancours anciennement colline de la
revanche pour ceux qui sont depuis
longtemps sur le secteur de 50 ans en
iveline et qui ont vu cette évolution
ceux qui ont également entendu parler
pendant de nombreuses années de ce
projet parce que ça fait plus de 20 ans
c'est qu'on parle de cette idée
d'installer une piste de ski sur cette
colline la population qu'on a pu
entendre en tout cas les gens gens que
nous avons rencontré ne sont pas tous
opposés à l'installation d'une station
de ski ce n'est pas votre point de vue
pourquoi et bien il y a plusieurs
raisons d'abord la première c'est que
c'est un aménagement sport loisirs
business qui ne correspond pas du tout
aux besoins des gens on est ça pouvait
peut-être fonctionner il y a quelques
décennies cette façon d'aménager le
territoire mais aujourd'hui on est dans
la politique de l'offre alors on fait
quelque chose en espérant peut-être que
ça va fonctionner mais je crois que ça
ne fonctionnera pas ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison c'est quand
même un frigidaire que l'on que l'on va
construire sur cette colline et que
c'est un gouffre à énergie alors j'ai
appris cette nouvelle le moment de la
semaine du développement durable à Manil
Amou sur la ville nouvelle et on
expliquait aux gens qu'il fallait
économiser un petit un petit peu de Wat
sur son éclairage sur toute une série de
de fonctions et là on va on va on va
brûler des des kilos et des kilow de de
d'énergie donc c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment une une une bonne idée il y a
d'autres raisons mais euh celle-là elle
est particulièrement imposante on va
développer un petit peu ces différentes
raisons qui vous opposent à ce projet
juste pour vous préciser que nous avions
invité bien sûr sur ce plateau la
communauté d'agglomération de sa-quentin
en Yveline elle ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer le projet de la station de
ski est encore dans sa phase de travail
de négociation avec une entreprise
privée en charge du dossier à ce stade
du dossier la communauté d'agglomération
est encore en phase de discussion avec
les partenaire et n'a pas d'information
particulières à donner voilà la réponse
qui nous a été formulée à notre demande
d'intervention sur le plateau notamment
du président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération l'agglomération qui se
charge de ce dossier vous nous avez
expliqué qu'il y a plusieurs points hein
l'économie d'énergie notamment la
création d'emploi aussi ça fait partie
des des raisons pour lesquelles vous
vous opposez ce n'est pas un bon
argument selon vous l'argument selon
lequel cela va créer de l'emploi c'est
pas c'est pas un bon argument parce que
euh l'emploi bien sûr que tout le monde
y est intéressé là-dessus ça serait euh
illusoire de dire que ce ce n'est pas
vrai ceci étant au nom de l'emploi on
peut pas accepter n'importe quoi y
compris sur cette agglomération nouvelle
euh dans le passé euh on n'a pas accepté
toujours tous les projets qui arrivent
je voudrais en citer un parce que quand
même ça concerne beaucoup le monde euh
il y a eu 10 il y a 10 ans des des
forages pétroliers qui étaient envisagés
sur Mani Lamo et donc sur
l'agglomération et le Parc Naturel
Régional euh tout le monde s'y est
opposé et pourtant ça aurait créé de
l'emploi de la richesse on aurait eu de
l'argent et cetera donc tout n'est pas
acceptable dans euh la la question de la
création d'emploi et puis vous savez euh
si on a euh des dizaines de millions
mettre dans une piste de ski on pourrait
aussi les mettre dans des
investissements productifs en faveur de
la santé de l'éducation du vrai sport et
euh et pas dans des dans des des choses
qui vont toucher essentiellement des
familles aisées alors que on est à côté
de certains quartiers qui à 20 € de
l'heure ne participeront pas à cette
activité ceux qui en non ben avec 3
heures de TGV ils sont à Grenoble hein
donc il vous avez été président de de
l'agglomération à l'époque villenous
8 83 ce dossier il en était déjà
question à l'époque non à ma
connaissance non euh on en parle
vraiment depuis une une quinzaine
d'années de de ce que peut me donner ses
souvenirs parce que c'est cette colline
elle a été construite artificiellement
c'est le point le plus rou d'Île- de-
France mais c'était les les déchets
inerte à priori encore que jeis pas allé
voir ce qu'il y a ce qu'il y a en
dessous mais en tous les cas euh c'est
c'est un c'est un point intéressant qui
pourrait susciter d'autres aménagements
d'ailleurs de quelquesuns de auos
interlocuteurs tout à l'heure on ont
suggérait qu'on le garde comme ça puis
que ça soit espace vert ou autre mais on
pourrait aussi fabriquer de l'énergie
sur cette colline on pourrait regarder
le le gros problème c'est que on n
jamais eu d'études pour regarder s'il y
avait d'autres projets que des projets
de loisirs euh au haut de gamme donc je
crois qu'il faudrait faire ça quand on
veut pas une chose on fait pas d'étude
alors alors a priori selon les
informations qui ont filtré hein je vous
le dis une fois de plus c information à
prendre avec des pincettes puisque rien
n'est officiel entre entre autres de
cette piste de ce couverte il y aurait
également hôtel restaurant panoramique
Centre de Remise en force remise en
forme pardon des sentiers de randonnées
une station de VTT également et puis
pour les transports des navettes
électriques et un téléphérique aussi
pour relier la station la base de
pourquoi pas sputnic et cetera on peut
faire également plein de projets mais si
le projet se faisait avec un partenaire
privé oui vous pourriez vous opposer de
quelle manière ah bah attendez là je
fais de la politique les décisions ne
sont pas prises l'aménagement du
teritoire c'est quand même pas une
compétence privée c'est une compétence
publique c'est-à-dire les communes ou la
communauté d'agglomération qui a des
compétences en matière d'urbanisme donc
c'est c'est un moyen puis je répète on
fait on fait de la politique vous savez
il y a eu d'autres j'ai dans dans le
dans le même genre il y a quelques
décennies il y a eu un grand débat à la
communauté d'agglomération sur la venue
de alin proste par exemple sur Guill en
courour donc voyez on peut on peut
discuter d'un certain nombre de choses
c'est pas pour c'est pas parce que on va
dire on va créer de l'emploi de l'emploi
de l'emploi qu'on va accepter n'importe
quoi vous en avez discuté en direct
justement avec les les élus non j'ai
réagi parce que on dit que le projet
n'est pas abouti ceci étant c'est pas
moi qui qui tient la plume des
journalistes donc j'ai réagi à la suite
d'un article de la presse locale je veux
pas faire de publicité ici alle-y
c'était dans Le Parisien aussi
notammentou tout à fait Paris euh et
donc j'ai réagi si si le Parisien a
sorti un article c'est qui c'est que des
gens le lui avaient donné un certain
nombre de d'informations hein donc voilà
j'ai réagi à partir de là euh c'est pas
moi qui ai fait l'information parce que
je vous dis on en parle depuis un
certain temps déjà j'étais encore élu à
l'époque nous verrons comment évolue ce
dossier dans les prochains mois et puis
bien sûr nous continuerons à inviter
l'ensemble des protagonistes à
s'exprimer vous serez donc une fois de
plus le bienvenu avec on l'espère
d'autres représentants cette fois-ci qui
nous donneront plus d'informations
officielles sur ce sur ce dossier merci
Alain le vote d'être venu sur ce VO
merci de m'avoir permis de m'exprimer
sur cette question